so let's talk season three there's been
a bit of a shift in the show it has the
usual comedy that we love but there's
also a lot of there's also a dramatic
aspect to season three that I think fans
are really appreciating is that
something that you looked forward to
about season three yeah I was excited to
get to really dive into why Freddy and
Carly took so many years to finally get
together
um and I think that it was fun getting
to do it on this revival because it's
more of an adult show now and we really
did make it with the original viewers in
mind so we really got to dive a little
deeper get a little heavier a little
more serious than I think anyone ever
expected iCarly to get yeah for sure and
that's the beautiful thing listen this
show has been on and in people's lives
for so long there were so many and there
are so many credit stands out there how
did it feel to finally be able to give
the fans what they want but I assume you
also wanted to take the time as an actor
to make sure that it was right
definitely I'm happy that I got to do it
with Nathan because I've known him since
we were 12 years old and we both care
about the show so much and we really
wanted to do right by all those people
that have been waiting for 16 years for
this to happen so
um it was just a it was a good scene
partner a good person to have
um because we both really wanted the
same thing and worked together to try
our best to get the best product out of
it
now I know fans are in for a shock with
the season three finale obviously you
can't say too too much but what can you
tease about the finale
so a large part of this season is about
Freddy's mom Mrs Benson getting married
to louvert so that's kind of a thing
going on throughout the season that
she's getting ready for the wedding and
I can say the final episode is all about
the wedding and the craziness that
ensues during that
um and there is a question that I think
a lot of fans have been asking since the
beginning of the series that's finally
answered in this final episode
interesting
that was nice perfect timing
you know I have to do it girl you know I
have to do it come on now listen you
have been playing this character for so
many years and this is a character that
has lived with so many people so many
people have attached themselves to this
character I think a lot of people have
based their own personalities or even
careers on this character when you're
out in the street is there something
that somebody once said to you about the
power of this character that kind of
stuck with you
um I would say the thing that I get a
decent amount that always means the most
to me and is just a really nice thing to
hear is when people come up that are my
age now and they say they grew up with
me like they'll be like I literally grew
up with you watching the show like we're
the same age or they're a few years
younger than me and that just is such a
nice feeling it's so cool to get to be a
part of someone's life in that way yeah
it's super cool and not everybody gets
the opportunity to really grow up
themselves with a character and you've
done just that and listen you are so
good in this like you really really are
and I think that's why this show has
really went on for so long because of
this cast which is just so fantastic I
know we're talking about a lot of
adulting in season three and listen
adulting is hard okay I hate adulting
I'm sure you hate adulting at times what
is the hardest part of adulting for you
getting up early in the morning to work
like I I just miss being like really
little and just like sleeping in until
like 2 p.m I mean I still do that
sometimes but but that's the hardest
part getting up early in the morning for
sure I'm a night owl me too I'm such a
night owl I'm not gonna lie before this
interview today I was like beating my
face in the mirror and I'm like who
thought I would be doing this at six a.m
same here I was doing the same thing I'm
right there with you
there we go I love seeing queer
representation on this series I think
it's so important to have just that
visibility and representation on a
massive show like this and you yourself
Miranda you have this like huge queer
following which I understand why I
really really do but what has it meant
to have the lgbtq plus Community really
rally behind you as Miranda and of
course Carly I think it's just it's
absolutely amazing it's like the nicest
thing in the world
um I think that Lacey who plays Harper
on the show she does such like we're so
lucky to have her on the show she does
such an amazing job in that character
she's one of my best friends in real
life and I just feel like the energy
like everything she she brings to that
part into the show we're just so lucky
and and yeah and obviously it's amazing
to have
um Everybody watch the show and know
like that we're behind them and that
they are fans of the show it's amazing
the gays Lobby or the gays love you
yeah we want this show to go on forever
but when the time does come in your own
mind and you don't have to say what it
is but I'm just curious in your own mind
do you have an idea of how you would
like this show to end
um I'm happy that Freddy and Carly are
finally together
um I I don't know I mean for me I'm just
so happy that I got to come back and I
got to hang out with Nathan and Jerry
again I mean I love them they're like my
family and to get to be a part of it and
play the character at an older age and
explore that and it's just it's been
great so however it ends I'm I'm just
happy I feel like we we've had a great
time
and it's been a great time are there any
particular story lines that you would
love to see play out in future seasons
is there something in your mind where
you're like damn that would be really
good I hope that happens okay so Jerry
who plays my brother Spencer in the show
he's against
um having like a long-term girlfriend
that's been something that we've wanted
to explore on this show but he doesn't
think that his character would do that
because he's kind of like a man-child
that does whatever he wants and
everything good just happens for him and
he's like a bachelor but I think it'd be
fun to see him have more of a real
relationship for the first time on the
show so that's just me pulling for that
but it would be it would be fun and You
released an album back in 2010 so we're
going on like 13 years now girl so crazy
but are there any plans to get back in a
studio and release some new music
um I don't know I love doing music I
loved getting to to go on tour and it
was such a fun part of my life I don't
know if I'm gonna do it again anytime
soon but
um but you never know maybe I still love
to sing and I play guitar so it's always
a possibility you should do it you
should do it listen do it people are
waiting get back out there you know what
strap that guitar on create some new
Tunes if you were to collab with anyone
in music who would be your dream collab
at this moment post Malone
oh gosh that would be iconic that would
be so good
that would be incredible listen it was
so great to chat with you uh
congratulations again on really just the
series it has been so impactful for so
many people all around the world and you
are just so great in it so thank you so
much and we will uh chat soon hopefully
that's of you thank you and it was great
meeting you